- No.
(laughing)
I wasn't recording this whole time.
Oh, that's so stupid.
I imagine you're this guy
and you've been putting off writing
a thank you letter to your grandma.
She sent you socks or
something for Christmas.
You even went and bought
the stationery to do it.
You have the thank you letter,
nicely wrapped in, but what anyway.
So basically every time
you think about doing it,
you start to feel this
inner sense of resistance.
It's a resistance you
can't seem to break past.
So instead of dealing
with that resistance,
you go and do an escapist activity
like playing Apex Legends.
So let's continue this
role play a little bit.
You're playing Apex Legends
for a couple of hours
and things are going well
and then it hits you.
It's an inner kind of
disgusting, guilty feeling.
It says if the anxiety of the thing
that you're avoiding starts
to pervade the activity
that you're using to escape
the thing you're avoiding.
Congratulations, in this
short little role-playing,
totally fictional experiment we just did.
You just experienced
the two types of pain,
the pain of action and
the pain of inaction.
The pain of action is something
we can all identify with.
It's that discomfort we feel
before we do anything constructive.
Anytime you think about doing
something that's constructive
and a little bit difficult,
there's that inner sense
of resistance that seems
to stop you from doing it.
And in order to actually
accomplish that thing,
you have to break through that resistance
and then you get it done.
That inner sense of resistance is like
it's a paralyzing feeling.
Breaking through this resistance usually
takes some good old
white knuckle willpower.
So while it's painful and
uncomfortable up front,
if you just take it on
the chin and deal with it,
you start to become stronger
and more able to deal
with it in the future.
You start to become somebody
who is okay with discomfort,
your confidence, your self efficacy,
and basically your whole life improves
because not only do you
feel better about yourself,
usually doing something constructive
makes your life situation better anyways.
It's kind of like a lose, win.
The lose is eating the pain
and the win is the redemption
that comes from that pain.
So that's the pain of action.
The pain of inaction is far more subtle
and it's a lot more sinister too.
And that's because it doesn't
usually feel like pain at all.
When you choose to play Apex,
instead of filing your taxes,
it may actually feel good for a while.
And it's a lot more fun to play Apex
than it is to file your taxes,
but kind of like binge
drinking on a Friday night,
you're just stealing the
happiness from Saturday morning.
And the debt you'll
have to repay afterwards
is far more painful than
just taking the initial pain
on the chin to begin with.
The pain of inaction is a slow
burning, degenerative pain
that ruins every aspect of your life.
By choosing the inaction route,
you become a softer person,
somebody who flinches at
the site of discomfort,
somebody who can't get stuff done.
And the consequence of that
on a long enough timeline
is you start to dislike yourself,
you start to not believe in
your ability to get things done
and your life starts to
fall apart around you.
You'll eventually dig
yourself into a hole so deep
that it seems impossible to get out of
until you're pained by the
misery of your own existence.
Obviously this is really morbid,
but it's nonetheless true.
Nobody can avoid pain in day-to-day life.
Pain is just something that
we all have to deal with,
but thankfully we can choose
which pain we deal with.
If you choose not to fool yourself
and take the pain right up front,
battle through the discomfort
of taking constructive action,
then you won't have this
massive pain debt to pay.
And the pain debt is the pain of inaction,
which is a lot more crappy in general.
So yeah, that's all I got
to say is choose wisely.
(chuckles)
I think that's pretty
much all I'm gonna say.
It's good to be back.
I just wanted to throw...
I actually put a lot of
thought into this video,
as short as it is.
I've been thinking about pain in general
and how sometimes life sucks,
but there's a lot of redemption
to be found in this pain
as long as you're aware of it
and make the right decisions.
Anyways, not to get too
preachy or anything.
So I'm gonna do a giveaway.
I've just decided this now.
So the folks over at Habit Nest,
they sent me the Nutrition
Sidekick Journal.
I don't even know if this is good or not.
I'm just gonna be straight up with you.
I haven't opened it yet.
It's brand new in its
packaging and you could be
the first to tell me how it is.
Click the link in the description.
There's just...
It's like super easy to
sign up for this giveaway.
It's just a gleam.io link.
And you have a really good
chance of winning this
in general because we don't
have a giant subscriber base
of millions of subscribers so
your chances are pretty good.
Thank you for watching.
I hope you liked this video.
As per usual, if you liked this
video, hit that like button.
If you like videos like this in general,
hit that subscribe button,
join our Facebook page.
It is actually one of the
coolest parts about this channel.
We have over 1200 members
on our Facebook page,
just sharing their advice,
tips and tricks as to how to improve,
how to be better in social situations,
how to improve their
diet, all of these things.
And we're going to open
a Discord very soon
where you can actually talk,
you can actually hear people's voices,
which is exciting.
Who doesn't like to hear people's voices?
Anyway, that's all for today.
Thank you for watching.
And we'll catch you in the next video.
(upbeat music)